I'm going to ask you, this spirited ghost appears in the place I
fell down in the room a little while ago, but why did I get 3 points
?  It's a good name, eh
, can you tell me more about it?
Eventually, the war ended and the inn became a normal hot spring inn, but before long
, rumors began to circulate among the guests that they had seen the ghost of an armored warrior.
The spirit was performed, and
since then we have been operating without any problems.To
tell the truth, we have been suffering from the pain of dying several times over the years.
It's been a while, but it's
gone before I
know it.It's been creepy for so
many times.Yeah, suddenly there was a loud noise.
A customer says,
but I can't find anything even if I look it up Ah, it's
definitely a ghost after all.
It's not strange, isn't it?
A figure in an open-air bath might just be steam, isn't
it?  It's definitely interesting